on the hill tonight for the giants will
be the
14-year veteran johnny cueto 35 years
old 511 225 pounder this year what do
you start our 21st start he's 7-6 with a
3-7-3 era
and with quito you know you're going to
see a guy that moves his stuff uses a
variety of movement and motions
a lot of things are trying to upset the
timing of the hitter so first and second
now for omar narvaez narvaez today's
cleanup batter in the first place he
swings at the first pitch this one to
right and that falls in for a base hit
adamus had to hold up for a second
they're going to wave him home and he'll
come in and score
yelts goes to third it's an rbi single
for omar and arvayas and a quick
one-nothing lead for milwaukee three
straight hits against johnny cueto that
change-up left up in the zone
adam has held up for just a moment to
make sure that that ball was not going
to be caught by lamont wade and wright
he was able to score without a throw
from brandon crawford
yell at your great read
he ends up at third for abi sayo garcia
runners on the corners first bit
swinging again slow rollers gonna score
a run bryant makes the play but the
second run comes home
on the rbi ground up from garcia it's
two to nothing check the numbers on
brandon woodruff and singing third best
era in the national league he's third
and opponents batting average he is
third in whip ground ball right side
wong charges fields throws in time to
get crawford and brandon woodruff puts
up a zero in the bottom of the first
despite the lead off double two-nothing
brewers hitting number two johnny cueto
to lorenzo kane swinging a high fly deep
into left field back dickerson way back
it is gone
halfway up the bleachers in left field
for lorenzo kane
it's three nothing brewers
sixth home run of the season for lorenzo
kane and there was no doubt about that
one
and a no doubter a back leg special for
lorenzo kane
and the brewers have a three to nothing
lead here in the second inning
kane touching up his
former teammate in kansas city that
hurts a little bit for cueto he had a
chance for the two three inning and he
had a chance to get it quickly and
garcia
battled him eight pitches and finally
goes to first roddy teles comes up he
hits that one into
left center field got some carry
yastrimsky on the run it's off the wall
takes a big bounce
rounding third headed home is garcia
tellez on his way to third it'll be an
rbi triple for rowdy teles
four nothing milwaukee he just missed a
two-run home run but
he doesn't get many of those he'll take
the rbi triple to make it four nothing
and now the brewers have him on the
corners with two outs has lorenzo kane
coming to the plate kane pushes one to
right a base hit
lorenzo kane with an rbi single tales
scores easily and lorenzo having a night
two hits two rbis it's five to nothing
brewers five nothing brewers brewers
have a two out base runner here with
omar narvaez coming to the plate
swinging a high pop up shallow left
field this could be some trouble
and now racing in dickerson he goes into
a slide and he misses it coming all the
way around to score is yellowish now a
throw to first base from cueto is wild
in the dirt it goes down the right field
line
now gets up and goes to second
that was a disaster for the giants
yelich scored all the way from first on
what looked like a sure thing out number
three it's just great hustle for the
veteran
we saw it last night i mean he hits a
ground ball routine ground play ground
ball he's running it out hard
you can see the way that the
defense was set up it wasn't going to be
easy play for anybody and i'm not sure
if dickerson even saw that ball for a
lot of the way but because of the hustle
from yelich a two-out jump
woodruff's got it going tonight six k's
two walks he's only given up one hit
mike yastrenski will start it for san
francisco struck him out swinging 97
with gas right down the middle strikeout
number is six
here's lamont wade
strike three call to change up right
down the middle and the inning is over
the giants trailing six to nothing to
the milwaukee brewers as brandon belt
will lead off here against the
right-hander brandon woodruff belt
swings it's a high drive in the deep
right center field going back as kane at
the warning track at the wall
[Applause]
into the milwaukee bullpen
beyond the leap of lorenzo kane
and for brandon belt his 20th home run
this year
first run of the night for the giants
brandon bell unloads and the giants are
on the board
congratulations brandon
158th of his career two pretty good
names that he just passed on that
all-time list
and cousins will enter with a five-run
lead
trying to hold serve and get this one to
the eight
singing well 20 second appearance of the
season look at that era 0.82 just
absolutely
dealing and
it's a guy with 33 strikeouts in 22
innings so yep he can
send guys walking back to the dugout
swing at a miss he got him with a
fastball three pitches and jake cousins
wipes out alex dickerson the giants have
drawn a couple of walks giants have
something cooking with brandon belt the
brewers killer
he went to the slider and he got him on
the strikeout and there's two away now
for buster posey swinging a miss he
struck him out slider off the outside
edge and jake cousins strikes out
through side here in the bottom of the
seventh inning and he is in line for the
win
would be back-to-back wins for woodruff
they'll give the ball to brent suiter
who's been a big winner this year struck
him out with a high fastball
a couple of strikeouts for brent suter
an academic mortgage rock solid
strikeout
gets the brewers out of the inning we
head to the ninth in san francisco 6-1
milwaukee the is three ounces away from
taking the first two games of this four
game series flores drives one deep down
the left field line this one on its way
it is gone
and the giants get a run on the board
here in the bottom of the ninth inning
wilmer's 17th home run of the year so
now the giants are down to their final
out belt
center field playable
kane is under it and the ball game is
over the brewers have won back-to-back
games in san francisco